there is panic tonight on Turkey's
border with Greece these images sent to
us were filmed by an Iranian woman she
is among hundreds who were encouraged by
Turkey to head for the border to Europe
through the day the tear gas is from the
Greek authorities securing their own
borders stopping the migrants men women
and children from entering the EU they
are now stuck in no-man's land between
the two countries along the road heading
towards the border we met more young men
from Afghanistan where have you come
from Istanbul how long have you been in
Turkey about one here about one year and
where do you want to go now we want the
one deliver to Europe from early morning
the images prompted a DejaVu that was
entirely intentional this is turkish
President Erdogan s way of reminding
European and NATO leaders what he can
allow to happen there are over three and
a half million refugees from all over
the Middle East in Turkey they've been
here for months and years prevented in
large numbers at least from crossing
into Europe because Turkey had been
sticking to a 2016 deal with the EU
until now
however the only thing gave them then I
heard the news and that's why I came and
want to go to Europe
we're coming from Istanbul our aim is to
get to Germany there are Syrians with us
Algerians Palestinians there are people
from every country further south on
another familiar route to Europe across
the Aegean Sea migrants moved to the
Greek islands which are already
overwhelmed it was enough to prompt the
EU whose leaders must be nervous to
remind Turkey of its obligations we
expect sirki to uphold its commitments
stemming from this statement and the
Turkish authorities officially confirmed
that there is no change in the official
policy no change in official position
and we expect that it will stay so and
the turkey will continue to deliver on
the commitments stemming from the new
turkey statement this is turkey's way of
pressuring the world
help out here inside Syria it's released
plenty of footage of its tanks and big
guns attacking Syrian forces trying to
repel their advance in Italy Turkey
fears up to a million more refugees
could cross if it doesn't stop the
Syrian bombardment but on Thursday night
a Syrian strike killed 33 Turkish
soldiers as Turkey buried its dead the
government called a NATO meeting but it
was rewarded with only words of support
nothing more Turkey wants a nato air
cover but it's not likely a perilous and
devastating civil war could be on the
verge of becoming even more dangerous